welcome back to law and crime daily
disgrace former attorney and convicted a
double murderer Alec Murdock was back in
a courtroom on Wednesday this time out
of federal courthouse in Charleston
South Carolina Murdoch entered a not
guilty plea to 22 federal charges which
included money laundering wire fraud and
bank fraud a Federal grand jury indicted
him on these new charges just last week
the indictment claims Murdoch took part
in three schemes to steal money from his
personal injury clients as well as the
family of his longtime housekeeper who
died after a fall at his country estate
when news of the indictment came down
dick harputlian and Jim Griffin
Murdoch's attorneys during his murder
trial released a statement saying
Murdoch had been cooperating with
federal agencies and that they
anticipated the charges would be
resolved without going to trial when
Murdoch entered a not guilty plea those
same attorneys indicated a deal could
still be in the works Murdoch is serving
two life sentences for the murders of
his wife Maggie and youngest son Paul in
you'll likely remember during his double
murder trial Alec Murdoch all but
admitted under oath that he stole money
from his clients for years he and
prosecutor Creighton Waters sparred
about the details during Murdoch's
cross-examination
I remember lying
to clients of mine I did it on
more than one occasion
I took their money when I shouldn't have
taken it I'm sure that I looked them in
the eye I'm sure that I misled them
but I can't tell you exactly when those
occurred 12 years ago is the only point
I don't dispute that day occurred
I don't dispute to everything about what
I did was wrong
but I can't sit and tell you the
specific details that you're wanting me
to give you
Terry the state is already pursuing
criminal charges against Murdoch for
these Financial crimes he committed so
what is the purpose behind the federal
charges well you know what Brian they
want to make sure that these charges
stick they're trying to get Justice for
the victims they're trying to get
restitution and prison time he could win
his appeal and if he wins his appeal
he's out of jail now that's very
doubtful but I think the federal
government is making sure that that
doesn't happen by bringing these charges
and also for the criminal Financial
crimes in State Court they cannot use
his testimony from the murder trial
against him so they probably won't be
able to do much with that case either so
I think this federal case is going to be
a very important case it's a little bit
more tailored they're only focusing on
what happened as far as the law firm is
concerned stealing from the clients and
money laundering but I think it's wise
of them to make sure that they pursue
this just in case everything goes wrong
in the state level yeah your honor we
thought there was going to be a plea
today but I'm sure as you know please
fall apart all the time what do you
think could have been the issue with
today's deal as and also as a judge do
you think there's a way to get both
parties to kind of get to that finish
line of a plea
well with regard to the question of why
the plea broke down today you know there
are always a million possibilities of
everything when it comes to a court so
who knows
um you know he could have been asking
for some consideration although he's
serving two life sentences so I don't
know what consideration he may be
looking for uh the state may have been
looking for some additional information
that he wasn't willing to provide
there's no way to know why the plea deal
didn't go uh go forward today but every
day is a new day and the deal could
happen any given day now when when the
the idea of
um you know why why a different move why
a plea deal why not that's up to the
lawyers and the person who's who's being
held over the fire whether they want to
get closer and Justice to the victims
absolutely well thank you for that well
a driver is still in the hospital after
her car went flying over a tow truck in
south Georgia take a look at this body
camera video of last week's crash
deputies and tow truck we're at the
scene of a Highway crash when a driver
hits the back of the tow truck's ramp
and launches into the air it hit the
back of another car on the way down then
traveled another 20 feet or so before
coming to a stop deputies rushed to help
the driver who had some serious injuries
one of the deputies was hit by the
flying debris but was released from the
hospital in good condition
welcome back to Long crime daily jury
selection started this week for another
case connected to the Parkland school
shooting prosecutors are accusing a
Florida sheriff's deputy of hiding
instead of taking action to save lives
five years ago on Valentine's Day 17
people were killed at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School in Parkland Florida
but defendant Scott Peterson was highly
criticized for running away instead of
helping people on the third floor of one
of the school buildings on that floor
alone sick victims died and four people
were injured Peterson's defense team
argues that the former deputy was taking
quote tactical cover at the time of the
attack as prosecutors charge him with
child neglect and culpable negligence
the judge is expected to decide next
week whether the jurors will be able to
visit the school building where the mass
shooting happened in the meantime jury
selection kicked off on Wednesday a
group of 50 jurors will be selected to
return next week and be narrowed down to
a panel of six jurors and four
alternates round one got off to a slow
start
you can't put any of that aside no okay
yes you don't think you can follow my
instructions
okay now listen sir I appreciate you
letting me know all right State you have
any questions yeah
you sat down you turned and said
something to the young gentleman sitting
right next to you and it was right after
looking at my client what did you say to
him
said I don't know if this is an
apartment case I don't know because it
says a lot of things is there anything
else you told him no
did you say anything else to any other
potential jurors
not no not a not a beer at home
but they're not yours
okay
nothing for okay stay based on that any
questions all right sir thank you very
much we'll give you a call back you can
turn it in at the Jury Room
Terry jury selection is uh if not the
critical part of any trial what type of
Juror will each side want in this case
well I agree it is a very critical part
of any trial you're going to want a jury
who is fair-minded not like that juror
who is sitting there who said he could
not be fair in this case and he could
not listen to the evidence so both sides
are going to want someone who can be
fair like that then I think the
prosecution is going to want parents on
that jury someone who can sympathize
empathize with what happened at that
school and I think there will be many
people who could be parenting who could
understand what could have happened I
think the defense is going to try to
find someone who is from a military
background or from a you know police
officer background so they can put
themselves in the shoes of this
individual who was faced with some very
risky and dangerous things that he had
to respond to so two different types of
jurors but all of the jurors will have
to be fair obviously Judge Rucker let's
tackle this issue as to whether the
jurors will be able to see the ins and
outs of this school the judge is going
to make a decision but I want to put you
on the bench for a minute as a former
judge how would you rule on this issue
because of the importance of the case
and really the the graphic nature of it
I would most likely allow for the the
jurors to to be able to visit the
location you know the defense's argument
is that he was making a tactical
decision and that's why he didn't rush
in well we're talking about tactical
decision the best evidence in my opinion
would be a site visit as opposed to
pictures photographs and architectural
designs absolutely and my thing is
they're saying guilty of what happened
on the third floor not the first and
second and this is a school that's
almost 75 yards long I agree with you
judge they got to go there